good day everyone and welcome I'm Jack Van
Horn from the University of Virginia and I
am very proud to welcome you to this edition
of our 2022 2023 foundations of biomedical
data science seminar Series this lecture is
supported by uva's integrated translational
Health Institute of Virginia the UVA brain
Institute the College of Arts and Sciences
the school of data science and through a grant
from the National Institutes of General Medical
Sciences since 2016 the foundations of biomedical
data science seminar series is focused on the use
of data science methodologies artificial
intelligence deep learning and statistical
modeling as they pertain to different themes in
the biomedical and Health Sciences this year's
theme is data science and the public health
consequences of the covid-19 pandemic where we
will be enjoying presentations on Fridays at noon
eastern time from leading thinkers on the issues
promise opportunities and hurdles associated
with understanding the secondary health effects
of covet 19. these include delayed Health
checkups treatments mental health drug abuse
increased obesity and the long lingering health
effects associated with the SARS covid-19 virus
indeed today we are excited to announce the
opening of our 2022-2023 application cycle and
encouraged Junior faculty members work in areas
such as infectious diseases epidemiology clinical
medicine population Health as well as data science
machine learning AI statistics and other relevant
domains to consider applying we believe this
will be an exciting and engaging program where
characterizing the secondary effects of covid-19
necessitates unique quantitative approaches but
also helps to develop new multi-disciplinary
collaborations participants in our biomedical
data science uh Innovation lab program will
leverage these seminar presentations as vital
material for our culminating in-person Grant
project development Workshop to be held at the
lodge at St Edward Andrew sorry Saint Edwards
Park in Seattle Washington in June of 2023. so
today kicking us off I'm delighted to welcome
our speaker Dr Orlando Lopez from the National
Institutes of dental and and craniofacial
research at the National Institutes of Health
Dr Lopez received his PhD from the Mayo Clinic
and his Bachelor of Science degree from Boston
University both in biomedical engineering
he is an alumni of the prestigious FDA
Commissioners fellowship and an NIH postdoctoral
intramural research training award fellow
Dr Orlando Lopez he currently is the director of
the dental materials and biomaterials program at
the National Institute of dental and craniofacial
research and he contributes to the programmatic
efforts to strengthen nidcr's biomaterials
portfolio and basic science translational
research as it's dedicated to the restoration and
repair of dental and craniofacial features he's
also manages technology and Innovation grants
under sbir and sttr programs additionally he
oversees interagency agreements with the National
Institutes of standards and Technology dedicated
to establishing performance standards for
dental materials prior to being at nidcr Dr
Lopez served as the lead regulatory reviewer for
the the FDA where he led medical device approvals
and imaging cardiovascular and digital Health
Technologies kicking us off today with our very
first seminar series of this season Orlando's
lecture is entitled rad medical approaches to
covid-19 testing surveillance surveillance and
predicting susceptibility to developing long
coveted or the pasc task program and so we are
super delighted to have Orlando and thank you
so much for joining us and getting us started
this year Orlando we look forward to your talk
uh you're you're muted Orlando so you'll have
to unmute okay thank you all right great so
thank you so much Jack on on June for the kind
of invitation to participate on the very kind
uh introduction as well so thank you uh so
I'm delighted to to be here um to kick off
this uh this series this really amazing series
that uh The Innovation lab has put together uh
to discuss some of the highlights uh from the uh
radical Raptors generation of Diagnostics program
especially in the radical aspects of development
we've really been um very excited and very uh
very busy very productive as well in the past two
years addressing this uh Public Health Emergency
Arena so definitely like to to share some of the
highlights and of course acknowledge uh you know
significant contributions from across all the
different program officers and the different
leadership aspects of of this initial and under of
course the researchers that are actually doing the
work in the field so um thanks again and um let's
kick this off here uh so today I'll be sharing
um different aspects uh and mainly uh at an over
um overview level around the specific aspects of
some of the Innovation and the charge of seeking
innovation in the covid-19 testing to address
the pandemia and and the different gaps in that
space looking at some of the discovery and data
Consortium and coordination centers that are part
of this ecosystem of emerging Technologies as well
as uh provide some key examples uh that are most
relevant to some of data um considerations that
were uh speaking about in this particular
series um and a newer emerging uh a new a
newly launched initiative on the long-cloud
computational challenge which uh it's open
uh for entries and uh definitely encourage this
community to participate in that effort as well
so the uh rapid acceleration for Diagnostics uh
covid-19 testing program um of course uh kicked
off early on in the pandemia uh charge from
Congress to auxiliary innovation in this space
and particularly address the shortage under on the
uh and the actual like limitations in performance
of whatever was existing because this uh virus was
non-existent before so there was really no targets
uh to to go by but uh the commercialization
piece is also very important and so a number
of different initiatives can bow uh to address
this uh early on in the pandemia and also looking
uh ahead in terms of long-term uh developments
uh what would be uh some areas that might be uh
a more early stage um you know more complex in
nature that needed some additional resources and
time to get to uh you know proof of concept and
viable commercialization Pathways but uh initially
uh the products that were most readily accessible
and that may be required just some more of the
manufacturing upscale aspects went into the Radix
Tech program uh which essentially uh addressed a
number of the different bottlenecks in the early
stages then there were other program areas that
were primarily focusing on the underserved
populations as well as the testing capacity
uh in in clinical tests testing facilities
the particular program that I'll be talking
to uh today is the radical which is you know
aimed to develop Advanced novel non-traditional
approaches with new applications not just
for covid-19 but also that have the potential
um in terms of viable platforms for future uh
disease detection and health monitoring uh you
know to address potential future pandemics and
other aspects of Public Health the data management
support came to be represented in the context
of data coordination centers that support the
different aspects of the different programs
here and I'll highlight some of the um most
recent accomplishments in those spaces so just to
give you a bird's eye view of um some of the the
significant challenges and also just the chromatic
uh you know complexity in the early stages that
um the Radix Tech program uh called you know
kicked off a solicitation on submissions were
accepted at the early stages of epidemia in April
uh several thousand I believe applications came
in and then all those projects were put through a
pipeline kind of like a shark tank type activity
and uh very few um actually made it all the way
but the ones that made it um you know definitely
got significant support across the board to be
able to to realize those those goals of of getting
um reliable testing deployed and when we see
that you know of course we still have a lot of
challenges in that space and and we're trying
to address that in in different areas so from
from the perspective of getting things to Market
is important to consider the overall biomedical
product development cycle and the different
entities and considerations that are of course
make part of this possible to get something to
Market so initially just you know at a conceptual
level uh starting from the con the discovery phase
ideation of a project and then going through uh
pre-clinical assessments I mean that's mainly
where NIH for the most part has a significant
uh role in terms of Bio ecosystem Innovation
ecosystem as the largest seed fund there for
biomedical research in the world um and then
the the projects ideally will iterate through a
number of uh you know research development Cycles
early stage characterizations to a point where
um uh proclinical safety can be demonstrated
primarily in order to start some human testing
then a clinical testing of course starts and then
other agencies get involved more involved uh some
earlier than others but the FDA of course is is
needed in terms of the regulatory oversight and
then reimbursement is of course very important
as well so initially clinical factors for product
development are really I think the key drivers for
r d especially at the early stages and things that
you know are are looked to go towards that um
you know user adoption Market entry perspective
and you know just like to highlight the safety
piece because a lot of times innovators want
to jump into the effectiveness right away without
demonstrating that the the Prototype is even safe
so it's important to to address those aspects
and and of course there's many other layers to
consider that are non-clinical in nature and
especially around the the business models and
and ways to Market that are course you know that
can make or break projects this is a you know
significant areas of product development that
we have been discussing and you know addressing
and trying to support a lot of these Technologies
uh so that they can find uh some streamlined path
to Market especially because uh in the context
of the Radix uh radical program these are very
novel technologies that perhaps have never been in
Market before or at least not for the particular
indications that we're looking to to support so uh
very closely we've been working with FDA and other
agencies to be able to leverage uh as much data
as possible from the ecosystem but also to come up
with optimal protocols and and policies that you
know help us support these emerging Technologies
and accelerate their not just the development but
guided development so that it will be aligned with
regulatory considerations and requirements
in the future so typically the the value of
debt for a lot of this technology especially
in the space of biomedical uh medical device
space it's the lacking the the design and doing
the pre-clinical characterization development
verification validation that the condensed support
representative aspects of the clinical performance
um so that's you know a lot of
the the considerations that we
um look for and uh and the way that we oversee
these type of projects you know as they accomplish
and move forward uh in their Milestones to to
reach the point where they can either become
Advanced Technologies for clinical testing
or maybe actually enter the market so again
just to highlight the radical Radix program uh
aims to support the non-traditional approaches
including Rapid detection devices for
home-based testing point of care that
address the the gaps then that was you know
two years ago but there's still significant
aspects of some of the gaps there in this space
but also of course we're looking for the future
and how some of these platform Technologies
company leverage for future applications
so the portfolio of the Radix rat program it was
a very is very diverse both from a technology
perspective so about 50 projects were funded
initially in the calendar year 2020 including
multiple novel Technologies across different
reflection schemes different indications different
environments of use different biomarker targets
and of course addressing different populations in
many different respects we funded uh I believe
11 or 12 different areas including the data
coordination Center and on each area you know it's
a portfolio within itself the one that I oversee
particularly is the novel biosensity Technologies
for the oral cavity and iOS participate in a as a
program scientist in other aspects of The Descent
program which is for detection of development
compounds as well as some of the predictive
prognostic work they'll be talking to briefly but
yeah so about uh 100 or so a million dollars were
awarded to his projects and we're working uh with
uh some of the projects that are more advanced in
nature some of them have not received additional
support supplemental funds to get into to the
next phase of the of the r d and and even to
some of the scalability and uh of the product
development as well as some of the regulatory
um streamlining of the of the evaluation is there
to get to Market so highlight I will highlight
a couple of uh examples from some of the novel
biosensing activities as well as the scent program
or scanning for covid-19 by electronic nose and
then some of the Wastewater detection as well as
uh some of the data coordination aspects as well
so for the uh the enabling Technologies the oral
devices um Technologies were really the foundation
for the Radix rad call that we put together
um uh from nitcr the National Institute of
dental and current official research so we
have uh invested in previous years prior to
the pandemia on the development of very novel
techniques uh to leverage the oral cavity um as a
way of access to not just the oral cavity itself
but you know the rest of the body where we can
look for potential indicators of overall health
and disease and and leverage that accessibility
for Discovery Diagnostics and Therapeutics and
so the oral cavity from an engineering perspective
is is quite a challenge um you know there's many
different forces a lot of chemical uh extremes
temperatures and of course you know everybody
eats and it sleeps and you know everybody has
a different you know their own routine and so
uh having uh an indwelling device device that will
go into the oral cavity and remain there for some
time and and remains uh you know robust in its
performance over time uh it's quite a challenge
but but if that can be accomplished um and in
meaningful ways uh it could be a very powerful
uh platform um you know for for
looking at health and overall health
um in the future and so uh that came as a platform
or Baseline for the Radix rat um call and we
combined with uh work with our colleagues at ncat
uh to combine these programs um and uh and came up
with a number of different activities and and we
are supporting 11 different projects in this area
um so this this was the call um that was put out
in 2020 and um and in the other uh call from the
uh ncats on The Descent program basically looks
to Leverage The the ability of canines you know
to uh send uh different aspects I mean there's
been some some reports and and verifications of
of canines detecting being able to detect cancer
or diagnose uh diabetes and many other aspects
so we're looking to mimic that capability into
an electronic form that could uh be used for uh
covid-19 but also you know of course other other
areas in the future so um look in a very developed
development of this novel Technologies uh looking
at unconventional detection strategies and
um and access and usability some some example
technologies that have emerged from from some
of these programs um very exciting around
contact tracing with privacy protection
um so of course you know privacy protection has
been a you know the Forefront of a lot of data
sharing and privacy aspects you know for for
identity insecurity considerations of of users
uh but uh but at the same time there's of course
significant value in being able to identify uh and
uh you know on track the potential um folks
that are infected in this type of scenario
and so uh this this particular development
allows for de-identified user inputs uh and
um you know looking at the locations I've been
able to actually have a user reported positives
and what you can see here in the uh in the graph
there the color graph you can see that there is a
there's an ability to um connect the dots and
look at a distance level to be able to assess
you know whether or not somebody's has a level
of risk or um for you know Contracting disease
and should be part of the contact tracing
and so on so uh this is a blockchain based
platform and you know this type of technology
has of course a lot of different possibilities
and potential in in this area but other areas
as well uh from the from The Descent program
um we have been able to uh get to a point where
some of these Technologies can actually uh detect
uh you know covet positive versus uh covet
negative patients uh just from uh different
uh volatiles that have been analyzed from
Excel breadth and so this is uh very exciting
um there had been no FDA approved products
for volatile organic compound detection or
to be used as Diagnostics uh there
was one that came up this past year
um and so that kind of sets the precedent for this
type of Technologies to potentially you know move
forward and get more advanced so some of the of
the different capabilities are basically uh you
know through the functionalization of materials
that get bound to you know specific uh binding
agents or targets uh related to the covid-19
virus or some other uh Excel breath chemical
and that's put through a process for detection of
these volatiles in in the vapor form uh some of
the protocols for the breath analysis basically
covers the uh taking the bread sample in a bag
uh the the the the material the gas materials
then pass through a pre-concentrator of of these
volatiles there's some gas hematography that is
conducted there is a different you know levels of
processing uh microfluoretics and then typically
there is of course you know significant layers of
machine learning AI algorithms that crunch through
all these different Spectrum the Spectra that are
produced for all these different chemical entities
and uh and then they're spit out some type of risk
factor or some type of indicator that could help
clinical decision on the diagnostic so this is
maybe some of the of the Spectra that come out of
this type of Technologies which are then analyzed
and then from there there is a determination of
of the detection of a particular compounds or or
the signature of a particular combination
of compounds that might be representative
of whether or not somebody has a disease or
the infection this is uh more data looking at
non-covet and covet there was even some uh there
has been some demonstrations around the detecting
differences between the different uh variants of
the virus and so this is you know really really
encouraging and you know these researchers have
done some outstanding work to get this technology
to where it is and we're very much looking forward
to getting this uh you know more further developed
um now to not shift gears a little bit to
uh the Wastewater detection of sarsko V2
uh this has of course been um uh really very
Innovative um sorry there's a alarm going by
um so yeah the uh the Wastewater detection
aspect you know of course uh came to uh to
be considered a significant uh significant tool
or potential tool to address uh the prediction
of of the uh covid-19 infections through uh more
more at a public health level a community level
um and so this is have been really exciting
um from a environmental perspective and many
others as well uh so some of the goals
for for this program have been around
the investigation of specific approaches
uh that could aim to to inform and optimize
um not just the sampling but also the
the detection of these waste Waters uh
demonstration and optimization of of the sample
analysis and then development of uh intervention
strategies that could actually make best use of
this data and the information gathered from it
which uh in many in many ways could be very
unique um and incorporate that into of course
um more advanced computational techniques
that that could be used for for uh prediction
um so some of the advantages uh for this
approach um could be that it could be a
really broad coverage across you know different
municipalities uh local entities it could be very
cost effective cheaper and faster than clinical
screening so like doing patient by patient um
there is some some significant demonstrations of
indications of Wastewater content and correlations
to covid-19 and that has been demonstrated
a number of different reports and papers
um and so so yeah so there's you know of course a
significant value here as well as the the ability
to complement other approaches and be able
to just you know make uh for for a stronger
decision making the more data that we have from
from different perspectives different risk factors
um so there were six projects that have been
funded through this initiative and and they're
all moving forward uh very productively
um and so of course data is key so
um like I mentioned there's the Radix rat program
uh has a data coordination Center component to it
which supports Administration and operations and
the logistics of some of data intake and sharing
from across the different projects um and uh and
the data management and use as well as supporting
researchers in different ways and so with that
I'll segue to into some of the updates from that
um the discovery and the data Consortium
coordination Center which is led by Dr Lucilla
Machado as well as Dr Shu and Dr Spencer and they
have um also kindly provided some some slides
um to provide some updates on this and so so this
schematic outlines this cup of work of the Radix
DCC now as you can see the project led by by the
different awardees the awarding team it's still
early early in the well it's not early but early
in the in the program DCC worked closely with
the NIH to arrive at a minimum set of common
data elements for cdes to be collected by all
awardees working with human samples since uh they
were the DC the DCC since then the DCC continues
to spearhead uh the formulation of common data
elements for research uh or scientific domain
um specific ones also known as tier 2 cdes um
here the the the new work process have been
developed to support the wide variety of
projects included in the Radix rad program
the DCC um also built tools for the identification
and limited linkage of patients for use by the
orders the identification was focused on
safeguarding information related to certain
um personal uh and file information which are
targeted by the NIH for infectious disease such
as zip code which reduce the the first three
digits only um the age shifted by by plus minus
two years and and dates of care measurements uh
were adjusted to minus or five plus you know of
plastics it is important to note that the Radix
threat program early in the definition required
all award is to submit only the identified
data according to the requirements approved
by the NIH leadership and this was important as
uh as it allowed for the Raptor transfer of data
to the NIH Radix data Hub and interim and in turn
to the researchers who have interest in the data
um then the final as mentioned earlier the DCC
also provide Benchmark samples to our word ease
so that they can normalize and ensure their
programs are verified using a defined bench
Benchmark the DCC um the gathers all the
data from the 50 awardees collates them
verifies that there are no residual um personal
identifiable informations uh in the data to a
global and transfers this to a global code
book that was developed later in the program
um and submit them along with the original
submission to the NIH terahub which in
turn receives data from other dccs
such as the Radix Tech or Radix up
so here the page provides a quick snapshot
of work accomplished unrecorded by the Radix
rad data Hub as mentioned earlier uh there are 50
awardees the 49 uh scientific awardees and and the
one is the BCC as part of the Radix program right
extract program uh of the 49 awardees 40 awardees
have shared data with the DCC including about 21
with multiple submissions in order to facilitate
common data elements the VCC has held over 100
tier two CDE meetings and has made significant
progress in some areas such as Wastewater exosome
and sent um the DCC has also shipped close to 500
samples to the awardees for their use to Benchmark
their work another important role played by the
Radix rad is to provide guidance toward these
in their interactions with the FDA and the DCC
has arranged 22 search meetings and help that
were these prepared and make best use of the
audience with the FDA the DCC has also held 34
were these prepare applications for resources one
10 licensing agreements and are in place between
awardees and commercialization organizations
um you can see a few more statistical
information in the other in the other slides so
now just a quick summary of the highlights
um we have spoken about the minimum of the
tier 2 cdes led by the Radix Radley CC and they
have also provided a prescriptive templates for
the data dictionary that can be leveraged
existing that can leverage existing or new
um or new surveys uh we have also spoken about
the Privacy technology and tools provided by
BCC another important support by DCC has been to
help the awardees navigate their institutional
irbs particularly for organizations that are
not academic uh institutions that have fewer
established work processes um data analysis
report and methodologies is provided to our
these particularly leveraging cross-learning is
facilitated by the Radix rat DCC of course one of
the key roles is to allow the smooth and Flawless
upload by their word is and on the NIH data hub
the Radix rad DCC has been instrumented
instrumental in uh in working with the
NIH Radix red hub to evaluate
new tools methods and procedures
the DCC has filled a vital Gap to provide tools
to the awardees they need uh to consistently
and correctly meet the identification of their
data and this is uh you this is used by several
about 10 or so of deliveries who have patient
information of a total of 20 who have patience
the others work with synthetic or non-identifiable
patients the the quality assurance tools allow
for automatic screening of a word compliance
with metadata data dictionary and data files
um contain constraints for
the Radix thread data hub
so from a work process Improvement the the the
main work work process was to develop a method
for building data dictionaries that would
function across a wide range of radically
different programs the DCC has made significant
progress in this and developed it the second area
is related to the dbgap registration as dbgap is
an NIH established identifier to streamline access
to secure data such as that gather under the NIH
Radix program the DCC has worked with awardees
and has obtained registrations of 47 awardees and
finally the DCC has developed new work processes
that has facilitated Flawless upload of the
data to the um you know STP FTP and is actively
engaged with supporting awardees to support
uh and submit their data to other Repository
stories across NIH and others as well so here are
just some statistics and the interest of time I'm
not going to go through them but you know I kind
of mentioned some of those already and uh this
is he has definitely played a significant um and
crucial role in supporting a lot of these projects
um now shift gears to um sorry this
is another from from another meeting
I borrowed this uh these slides but uh this is
for the long covet competitional Challenge and
um this is another very exciting opportunity and
a newly launched um challenge price competition
um that uh and we will provide a brief overview on
the objectives of this Challenge and information
on how you can participate and the breakdown of
the price per totaling up to five hundred thousand
dollars uh everyone is welcome to participate
in this Challenge and we definitely appreciate
um you know the members the audience uh
spreading the word on this uh the uh the
submission period uh was from when
he was launched in August 25th and
uh submissions will be received
until December 15th of this year
so I'd like to acknowledge the NIH
leadership and all the contributors that have
um you know made some efforts uh to put
together and launch these ChalleNGe Program
uh there had been a there has been a number
of contributors from across NIH many different
programs uh including I'd like to also highlight
and acknowledge my co-chairs for this program I'm
one of the co-chairs for for the for the challenge
as well as Dr Aaron iteriaga Yvonne Schulman
um and uh Chen also contributed significantly
to this to this particular program
so the community challenge is an NIH long um
covet computational challenge it's a community
Challenge and a community challenge is a is a
crowdsourced benchmarking effort which aims to
accelerate research by seeding and strengthening
a research community and addressing an important
scientific or biomedical question the format of a
challenge is broken into three parts first comes
the question then to build and then the Benchmark
the question is a research question that the
challenge organizers pose and is the guidelines
that the focus of the research Community uh
to the topic that the NIH is interested in the
build is the portion of the challenge where the
participants build a method to answer the question
and The Benchmark points to um The Challenge where
the challenge organizers judge the build or
method that the participants created against a
set of gold standards so the challenging tends
to accelerate the innovation of software tools
to improve understanding of risk factors and
support the clinical prognosis of long covet
now for an overview of the l3c Challenge and
uh just a quick background on the condition
the actual clinical driver for this is uh that
the overall prevalence of post-acute sequela of
sarskovic II also known as pasc uh and and as well
as long covet are currently unknown but there is
growing evidence that more than half of covid-19
survivors experience at least one symptomatic
pass for long covet at least six months after
recovery from acute illness uh the long-term
effects are on persistent symptoms of covid-19 uh
can affect anyone including children and it can be
um you can developing people who had asymptomatic
mild or severe disease reports also reflect an
underlying heterogeneity of symptoms multi-urgan
involvement and Persistence of pass or long covet
in some patients symptoms of fatigue cognitive
impairment shortness of breath and cardiac damage
among others have been observed in patients
who had only mild initial disease despite
ongoing research and significant need remains in
identifying prognostic factors that can reliably
support clinical decisions for the management
and prevention of past long covet in sarskovic
to infected individuals foreign complexity of
data created in today's Health Care encounters
require Advanced analytics to extract meaning
from longitudinal and data on symptoms laboratory
results images functional tests genomics mobile
health and wearables written notes ehrs and and
other relevant data types Advanced developments of
software tools and Computing capacity has allowed
artificial intelligence and machine learning
approaches that are increasingly demonstrating
the potential to provide insight into patient
level data from large amount of data to better
understand the effect of Sarasota on patients
to complement other NIH long coveted research
initiatives like the research in covet to enhanced
recovery program that are known as recover the
Radix rack program at the NIH launched a long
coveted computational challenge also referred
to as the l3c to support Creative data-driven
Solutions that meaningfully Advance the current
understanding of the risk to developing past and
local covet challenge participants will utilize
the the identified electronic health record data
available to the incats and 3C data Enclave The
Enclave is a central harmonized data repository
that represents electronic health records from
over 74 Healthcare centers across the U.S and
to protect patient privacy the identified data
provides information useful to researchers without
revealing any information that could identify
individual patients and for the information on the
n3c might be available in a couple more slides but
there is definitely the links that folks can refer
to for additional information and also uh to ask
questions about you know some of this program
um so in terms of the objectives of the program
uh the l3c challenge uh aims to focus on the
prognostic problem by developing AI commission
learning models and algorithms that serve as
open source tools for using structured medical
records to identify which patients infected with
sarskovic 2 have a high likelihood of developing
task or long covet understanding risk factors may
help clinicians better understand the underlying
etiology of the past and long covet condition
models will be evaluated using patients who have
had an ICD 10 code related to to the disease
and recorded in the data set and label as true
positive of patients with past or long covet
and future funding opportunities related to this
topic may become available uh if this channel
Beyond this challenge announcement depending
on the state of the science uh Public Health
need at that point and availability of funds
for for further development of of these models
and algorithms uh into more advanced tools that
can support clinical decision making not just
for covid-19 but maybe for other areas as well
so one of the one of the challenge as one
of the challenges of the challenge is that
um we have a you know there's definitely a
issue with the definition of past and long covet
um the the working definition continues to change
uh with new evidence and is challenging given
that it encompasses a multi-organ effect uh and
and seen in this disease um covid-19 positives
are defined for this challenge as patients who
have had a positive covid-19 PCR test not just
a diagnosis and we Define patients who have had an
ICD-10 code recorded in data set as true positives
there will be further explanation um and there is
also a recorded uh webinar on this and so I think
I'm gonna just kind of skip through all this but
uh most folks are eligible uh to participate there
is some challenge participation rules that uh are
provided uh in this website these are two that
you know we like to highlight The Prize winners
um are expected to deploy their solution uh as
open source uh resource to the community and so
the recently the prices contingent on that and
there is also um you know requests or requirements
for having established data use agreement to be
able to use the data within the n3c Enclave so
definitely a point folks to to those resources
and and just to become familiar with with the
rules there so in terms of the n3c repository um
the the data represents over 15 million patients
uh it's I believe that the largest repository in
the world for covet related data and that's what
we're going to be using uh the data set includes
information such as demographics symptoms
and so on you know like a lot of the EHR
type of information there is observational medical
outcomes and partnership um in the model the model
is the one that is used typically for getting the
data on and harmonizing it and the ic-10 ICD-10
code is is basically the uh the ground Truth uh
in within the the database but uh you know folks
are able to bring in other creative ways to um
to check against that that's also very welcome
so there is the there is access to the data and
so establishing access to the n3c and click uh
it's the does the required data set um and
people will have access to the uh sequester
data that has been reserved for this Challenge
and so everybody has to go through that process
um the timeline um we submitted the paperwork
uh in yeah and so sorry the uh this is for the
n3c Enclave onboarding um of the enclave and
so submissions are due by the 15th of December
and the winners are going to be and I'm gonna pass
Bridge through these but there is of course uh
judging uh criteria the first prize will have um
uh part of 200 000 second price of 150 the third
prize 100 000 and there will be five projects
that will be selected for honorable mentions
of 50k each and these are some of the resources
and links that folks can follow up with uh to
um ask you know to have more information about the
challenge but as well as to submit their questions
so with that I thank you for your invitation
again and your kind patience uh definitely
be happy to address any questions that I
can thank you so much Orlando thank you so
much that was a really great overview of
this kind of really exciting opportunity
um some of the activities which have been going on
uh at the NIH concerning uh covid and monitoring
Technologies and and so forth what an exciting uh
opportunity for anybody who wants to kind of get
involved in and get access to uh some of that
data from the uh uh the n3c in particular just
as a little aside um Johanna lumba who is one of
the people that you mentioned on your uh your uh
committee that's putting uh some of the challenges
together she's going to be um taking part in our
efforts here um through our biomedical data
science Innovation lab we're hoping to have
her come join us in Seattle next summer to uh
talk and uh about the data and to present it
um more formally and get people engaged with it
so we're super excited about that one question
I wanted to have for you or that I have for you
is um what are some of the roles for that people
who are data scientists that are what what
extra things could they do if they were able
to get access to this data one of the things you
mentioned was um on some of these Technologies
some of the safety and the effectiveness of that
data or or the the Technologies which are being
produced would any of the data be available to for
people who are so interested to say get access to
it available through the dccs um and like look
at elements of safety and effectiveness of these
various Technologies uh sure no thank you that's a
great question um well I at this point um I'm not
sure exactly if the data is available openly but
it's been is being acquired um not all projects
are able to contribute in the same way uh some
are sbirs ttrs like Small Business Awards and
some of those projects of course have um you know
IP protection confidentiality considerations and
so not all the data will be available but but I
think in if not available now in due time there
might be some data that might become available
from uh from some of the DCC repositories that
have been put together so uh this is uh it's been
about like a two and a half year effort so far and
so DCC started from scratch basically and so they
have been working very diligently to to structure
the intake of data and formulate all the processes
and so on so I would expect that you know some
availability of data might become uh you know not
now down the pipe that's fantastic and um I the uh
ChalleNGe Program that you described uh is super
exciting will be super exciting for people who are
um interested in this particular topic and
I'm curious if you anticipate the challenges
happen more challenges happening in the future
around other elements that leverage these data
oh absolutely I think that that that's um
that's something that we are exploring um
this uh l3c uh challenge is um a first challenge
in in this in this space at least for us and
um so it's definitely been a learning lesson also
for us I mean NIH and certain uh groups within NIH
are of course Very Savvy and very experienced
uh running challenges in many different
um in many different areas you know
addressing very different topics
um so we are definitely learning from this
experience and like I mentioned uh in the
presentation for their future funding might become
available around this particular topic and so it
depends on the outcome of this challenge I guess
we'll make some determinations as to you know
maybe having additional uh calls or leveraging
this type of mechanism for other areas so that's
to be determined but uh but it's a it's a very
exciting way to um and to accelerate Innovation
um especially in a in a space that uh that's
very much of in need but there is very exciting
uh potential technologies that could help address
uh some of those challenges so so it's definitely
a great way to to leverage and maximize value
across the way so definitely see that as happening
more often uh I just don't know exactly how that
will become part of the process here right right
well it would just be uh the the timing for your
December 15th deadline here for our biomedical
data science Innovation lab activities doesn't
quite line up that would be a little too quick for
us but uh if there were a second phase that dealt
with other dimensions of covid related data that's
available through the n3c for example or for maybe
something's available from the folks at San Diego
from the DCC that were available for a secondary
challenge it was due next uh I don't know next
fall for example our biomedical data science
Innovation lab teams that are going to be forming
would be in pole position to be able to compete
with clever projects for uh for those challenges
um yeah I noticed it's um another a number of the
you mentioned one in particular project that was
looking at kind of contact maps of people who
you know and using the blockchain technology to
kind of anonymously keep track of people in their
contacts and whatnot and um that looked like that
just from eyeballing the slide it looked like it
depended heavily upon graph Theory and network
Theory and that is certainly something that's a
particular interest to folks in this community I'm
curious if you could say a little bit more about
that particular project or any of the success
stories that it has had um yeah well unfortunately
I'm not always overseeing that particular project
um okay I'll be happy to you know to provide the
uh the contact for the program officer that is
leading that um so yeah so I'm not you know uh
sort of up to speed on on the specifics of that
project besides the uh the high level um you
know overview that I provided but uh but I am
very familiar with a lot of the blockchain type
Technologies and so in general uh of course you
know they have significant potential uh in
the context of uh provenance uh immutability
um yeah and being able to really establish trust
uh on a robust way to uh to have reliable data
uh so in that in that context uh I think
that that decentralization of of elements
um uh I think sets well for this particular
Network approach of contact raising because
uh that is of course an important piece there
the identification element I think that that's
a unique way also to leverage a lot of this data
and so looking at Federated learning systems and
graph theory of course you know facilitates a
lot of the the the correlation or the mapping of
of different uh data assets or
different you know information
um elements and so I can definitely see you know
these Technologies uh becoming more and more uh
you know part of of this platform or this type of
platforms for the future as as these Technologies
of course become more more available and and
folks are becoming more in tune with their
value because I think still some element of
of blockchain in particular compared to to AI
That's still somewhat fuzzy to to folks uh uh
but nonetheless I think uh you know there's no
single like Silver Bullet so I think it's the
combination of a lot of this technologies that
um very cleverly integrated uh can can
definitely deliver value and address a
lot of the significant aspects of uh you know what
what are some of the emerging concerns with this
um you know digital Technologies and connected
Healthcare including some other tips elements
I'm very involved in one of the IEEE um
standard development around the uh the
integration interoperability of of clinical iot uh
data and devices and uh we're looking to address
the tips component so the trust identity uh
privacy Protection security and safety mode
uh in addition to that of course we need to think
about the ethical components and a number of other
aspects in that in that line of of um development
of these Technologies in addition to the safety
and the effectiveness which are you know sort
of the underlying performance requirements
but now that we're bringing in all these other
emerging texts we need to start thinking about
um you know other elements on how to build
trust um you know in the ecosystem and of
course by the patients and the clinical
users that are going to be relying on them
yeah it was interesting when um
the the contract contact tracing
um the digital Technologies I was on a trip in
Europe and contacted contracted covid uh when I
got home and I got a notification after I had
recovered through my phone that I had been in
contact with somebody while I was on my European
trip which was a little too little too late so
obviously some further technology technological
development needs to happen but one thing which
is particularly interesting is the waste water
um Technologies and one could imagine these being
deployed in the Wastewater management system
of a particular building of a village um a
town and then being scaled up to cities I'm I'm
curious if there are any technologies that will be
scalable to be able to assess you know not only
individual homes but maybe communities as well
um yeah well that's a that's a great vision
uh and I I believe that that's probably part
of the plan to to some of this um I think at
this point we're still um at the high level
um sort of verification and validation stage
that there's been of course some some very uh
promising reports on on this uh in terms of like
being able to use Wastewater um detection for
covid-19 and and being able to predict uh a new
wave of of infection maybe about two weeks or so
in advance and so that's uh that's definitely very
promising and so from from a number of different
um considerations in the context of Public Health
surveillance I think that this will just become
uh in time just another tool in our arsenal of
uh you know this emerging like novel techniques
that are really I think very powerful and and when
they are validated which is I think the you know
the significant part of the challenge but once we
have them embedded and well established I think
that you know this all together will really
change the the the Paradigm of how Healthcare
um it's is actually practiced in many aspects
uh by accessing reliable information to
really enhance decision making so I think
that's a very exciting future ahead of us
Orlando I want to thank you so much for
summarizing uh all these different activities
that the NIH has going on um these are all very
exciting it's I think would be very appealing
for a lot of our potential participants and as
sources of data or sources of inspiration to
kind of think deeply about where data science
could play a role some of the computational
Technologies which could be deployed to
help in terms of the technology for uh
kind of early detection for long-term tracking
for discriminating between different coveted uh
variants Etc it's all super exciting um I want
to encourage everybody uh to consider applying
for our biomedical data science Innovation lab
activity uh the deadline will be January 8th and
applications are being received up until that
point um there'll be a priority for folks who
apply early this result the part of the program is
taking part in a few online activities in addition
to these seminar series as well as being
able to take part in our in-person activity
um to be held in Seattle Washington
next June uh check out our website
innovation.lab.virginia.edu for further
information and uh and application materials
as well once again Orlando thank you so much uh
this has been wonderful and uh I hope that uh
anybody who has any questions for Orlando will
reach out to him directly and we want to thank
you and we'll everyone have a great weekend
we'll see you all soon thank you so much